[Music]
what's up you guys so we have a few
updates we want to let you know first
off we're gonna do away with the slogan
real opinions uh no real news real er
opinions yeah so when we first create or
first of all like these update videos we
realize that we actually have a YouTube
channel which means we could talk to you
guys so we wanted to update you guys on
things that are started happening and
hopefully have more update videos and
not just the talk show videos but so
with the real news real real er opinions
that was a model made with the but the
beginning of the channel when we started
like 2013 or something I think so it's
been so long and then we realize it's
kind of redundant yeah that's in the
name it's like we're having fun with the
news with stories or like we don't need
real news real it appears we're gonna
take that out and another thing is we
get a bunch of new fans and sometimes we
forget because we have this connection
with you guys that new fans come in like
what the [ __ ] what is this and they're
all like confused so yeah because I hear
real news real or opinions you think
that our opinions are 100% of fact but
some others mess around just shootin the
[ __ ] talking and it's just us having fun
you know yeah like we say some crazy
[ __ ] and is that a real opinion no
sometimes yes sometimes but I don't want
everyone to think all of it is real
especially the peddle Bart character no
that's fake for now the second update we
have is we're gonna try our best to get
our videos out more up-to-date so we're
gonna shoot twice a week now
yes shorter times and that way we can
stay on top of you read the comments and
you guys get on this stuff I mean oh and
it's because of our process or we're
trying to adjust our process to that no
it's not gonna be like breaking news
because at the end of the day what this
is is we're just shooting the [ __ ]
having fun talking about what happened
right so if something happens
immediately your life
you're [ __ ] 30 minutes late
j/k news or whatever please chill
because what we're gonna do now is try
to get it like within a day or two so
because of that sometimes we'll have
videos that are like we'll post three or
four videos in one day and in the next
day there might be one video but I
guarantee you guys every day there's
gonna be a video so stay tuned for that
is just gonna be all over the place
yeah and the next thing to look out for
is we're gonna be shooting a channel
trailer we realize we're very
irresponsible youtubers and this is
something everyone's been doing already
there's already a trailer on a bunch of
YouTube channels so we want to shoot a
little traitor
shoot a little trailer so that people
they come on the channel they'll know
what's at what it's about a little
summary getting link your friends if
you've been trying to get your friends
on JK news and you don't know which
video to send them you can show them the
trailer and then give a summary on there
all that's true that's what they could
use the trailer for it's like this is
what this channel is about yeah that's
true this is the [ __ ] that I listen to
the more you yeah cuz sometimes it's
like why are these guys talking about
banana and I'm trying to look about I'm
trying to watch news about a recent car
crash that happen or like this is the
master title why am I watching this yeah
watch the channel trailer yes and
anyways for a lot of you guys that's
been watching for many many years and
some of you guys that just started
watching thank you guys for all your
support
we really really cherish and love all of
that I mean I'll be writing that comment
reading the whole team's reading
actually and so that's been pretty cool
because lately I've been seeing a shift
and there's been so much love and so
much like actual support from you guys
and the comments been really dope yeah
thank you guys for all the continued
support and hopefully look forward to
more update videos in the future see you
guys next time
[Applause]
[Music]